-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're back in the studio.
We hope you're doing well
and now,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden is reportedly
planning to communicate
more directly
with the American people,
in an effort to increase
his poll numbers,
so, you might want to switch
to the unlimited plan.
"Uh-huh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Build Back Better, right.
No, okay.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
No, Amtrak's great.
Listen, I have to be like up
in like four hours.
[ Laughter ]
House Democrats are reportedly
urging party leaders
to abandon President Biden's
Build Back Better bill
and, instead, break up
the proposals into a series
of smaller defeats.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate today took up debate
on a House-passed
voting rights package
that combines
the Freedom to Vote Act
and the John R. Lewis
Voting Rights Advancement Act.
Of course,
it's already dead in the water,
thanks to Can't Act
and Won't Act.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
In a new interview, political
strategist James Carville said
that Democrats should,
"Just quit being a whiny party
and get out there and fight
and tell people what you did."
Said Democrats,
[ Whining ]
"That sounds hard!"
[ Laughter ]
Former New York Mayor
Bill de Blasio announced today
that he will not run
for governor.
He then announced
something else,
but no one heard it
over the thunderous applause.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A video gained attention online
over the weekend
of Oklahoma Pastor Mike Todd
spitting in his hand
and rubbing it onto his
brother's eyes during a sermon,
[ Audience ohs ]
which is weird for a pastor,
but very on-brand
for an older brother.
[ Laughter,
smattering of applause ]
Health officials
in Greece yesterday
imposed a vaccine mandate
for all citizens
over 60 years old.
So, if you're a 60-year-old
in Greece,
you're Rizzo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I had a very depressing thing
just happen where,
you know, there was one person
enthusiastically liked it
and I'm like, "Well, at least
there's one audience member here
worth their salt!"
[ Laughter ]
Then I turned around
and it was Amber.
[ Laughter ]
It was our writer Amber Ruffin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And now, I'm starting to think
you didn't even laugh
at the joke!
I know, Amber, you were laughing
at how it went!
[ Laughter ]
You're out of the Pink Ladies!
[ Laughter,
smattering of applause ]
I never do this during the show,
but we're going
to stop it all down
and make everybody
watch "Grease."
[ Laughter,
smattering of applause ]
[ Laughing ]
A man --
[ Laughter ]
A man in South Dakota
was arrested recently
after his mother served brownies
that he made
with marijuana butter
at a senior center.
Caretakers became suspicious
when that night's comedian
got laughs.
[ Laughter,
smattering of applause ]
The FDA last week approved
the first treatment
to control arthritis pain
for cats.
It will replace
the old treatment --
a brick and a burlap sack.
[ Laughter and booing ]
We got to clear the palate!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
And, finally --
And, finally,
according to a new study,
men who live alone for years are
at a greater risk
of developing inflammation.
It's just a lot of stress
to put on one wrist.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
Makes you reassess
the dead cat joke, though.
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue.